Hey guys welcome back!!!
I'm Nate with the king of random
And today we're gonna be showing you how to make your very own
Replica from a video game.
In a recent video I got to show you something fun i built for DevinSupertramp.
Some giant Mario kart shells that I drove around on remote-control cars
Like I said I would i'm now going to show you how I did it so you can make your own
No interest in Mario kart?
That's all right you can use the same methods I'm gonna show you
To make whatever kinds of props you want
In the video where I showed these shells off
I had these giant 2 foot fibreglass shells
We're going to be scaling those shells down
So it's a little bit more manageable but the same principles can be used for smaller
Or much larger projects
The purpose of today's video is to learn how to sculpt
and prep one foot Mario kart shells out of foam
The materials for this are pretty basic
This is called rigid insulation foam
It comes in sheets that are about 1 or 2 inches thick
and you can usually get it in pink or blue at hardware stores
The full-size sheets are usually 4 feet wide and 8 feet long
To make it so I could fit the pieces into my car
this one is cut down to 1/4(quater) of that size
So it's 4 feet long and 2 feet wide
This is the 2 inch foam and it's what we're going to be using today
These shells are tall and almost spherical in shape
So we're gonna cut out 6 of the squares from the foam
Glue them all together and that will give us a 1 foot cube
we have our marks measured out
And now we're gonna use this handheld miter saw
To cut out the individual squares
We have our six squares cut out
And we're ready to glue them together
But this foam is made from polystyrene
Which can be dissolved by the solvents
And a lot of types of glue
So what we're going to use
Is this expanding foam in a can
It glues the foam together really well
And it doesn't dissolve it
Shake your can of expanding foam well
Apply a thin layer of the foam
And press your next piece down on to it
I Like to use bamboo skewers stuck in through the sides
To keep it from sliding side ways while it dries
Glue all six pieces together using skewers on each layer
And place a weight on top to help minimise the expansion of the foam
Always wear gloves when we're using this expanding foam
Because it's really sticky and very annoying to have on your skin
Also make sure you're wearing clothing
If you're okay with getting dirty
Depending on the temperature and humidity
The foam will take an hour(60 minutes) or two to dry completely
Once it has it will be rigid and inflexible
Our expanding foam is dry
So it's pull out the bamboo skewers
Sometimes they're glued to the foam on the inside
So it's good to have a pair of pliers to help with grip
That one doesn't want to come out
We'll probably run into that skewer
While we're trying to carve the foam
It'll be a little bit annoying
But we just cut it off as we get to it
Our foam is now ready to go
So let's start marking up the design
From the top down these shells are fairly round
So i'm going to draw an ellipse on the top of the foam
And then carve off all the sides until we have a cylinder
I'm going to be using the same handheld miter saw
That i use to divide the squares up
It's narrow and it's straight and it
does a really good job of cutting through the foam quickly (screeches!!!)
after the quick cut with the saw
And very rough sandpaper
Will help you take down the ridges left in the foam
Now, we have our cylinder
Let's start adding some basic details
These shells have a ridge around the middle
With a little bit of a curve in it
So i'm going to draw that in
First i'm just adding a mark
Where the front and the back are
So I know where the curve should begin and end
This line i'm gonna draw that goes all the way around
Will be the highest point that I want the ridge
This second line will be the lowest point of the ridge
You, can see that i have now drawn this band going all the way around i'm now going to use a thin razor blade to cut
About an inch in all the way around the band so that when i cut down from the top the piece will break off
There's a bamboo skewer that wouldn't come out of the foam i just sliced right through it with the saw
Now, we will do the same thing on the other side
sounds like bamboo
that is
okay guys
update
We can now start to see the very basic shape of the shell start to emerge and it's time to take down the excess and
give it that nice dome shape you can use a saw for taking down the large pieces of if you want but one of my
favorite tools for shaping this foam is some 36 grit sandpaper it's very rough and takes down the edges quickly
okay we've got
A dome for the top of shell coming along quite nicely
Now let's move on to the bottom of the shell on the bottom these shells do have something of a neck at the front which
Looks a little bit like a doughnut so the first thing we're gonna do is carve out a place for that
first we'll draw a line to keep it centered
Now let's take our razor blade and do the same thing we did with the ridge going all the way around i'll cut around the neck
and then saw down pieces of the foam to that point
now that we've got the neck blocked in let's go back to using the saw in the same paper to take off more foam and
block in the bottom shape of the shell
we've got our basic shape carved in now let's open up the neck hole and sand down and refine all of our edges to open
Up the neck hole you could use sandpaper or razor blades if you're really patient but i'm going to use a rotary tool to speed
things up a bit
eahhh
foam everywhere just it gets everywhere
Now that we've taken down the ridges let's go over the whole shell with a high grit sanding sponge to smooth it all out
We smooth down the shell and now the only thing left, to do is put in the four indentations that are the turtles leg holes
Our shell is carved and smoothed down now all that's left is to carve in the shell ridge pattern on the top and the belly
lines on the bottom after i draw in those lines i'm going to carve them in using sandpaper wrapped around a pen
now that we've added in our ridges this shell is ready to prep for the mold if you remember i explained that there are a
lot of chemicals that can melt the
Polystyrene that this foam is made from so what we're gonna do is cover the entire thing in a protective layer of
latex house paint that will form a barrier that will let us do minor repair work and apply mold rubber that won't stick too much
To the foam since the color we're going
to be using doesn't matter at all
You, can usually go to a paint store and ask if they have any incorrect mixes they'll often be sold at a steep discount
There you have the paint is dry and the only thing left before our shell is ready to mold is to use a little bit
of spackle to fill in any gaps or cracks or pieces that may have chipped off in the carving
spreading this spackle a little bit to try and fill in some of the really rough texture
Now, i've got lots of the gaps in cracks filled with the spackling i like this kind because when it's wet it's a very bright
Pink color but as it dries it starts turning white so you know when it's ready
To sand or paint here we go the pink spackling has all turned white which means it's ready
To be sanded and as soon as we've done that the whole shell will be ready To be molded
i'm using 400 grit sandpaper just, to smooth down spackle
There you have it our turtle shell is now built
Sculpted fixed up and prepped and it's ready to be molded which we're gonna show you how to do in our next video to recap
Our process we took some two inch rigid insulation foam and cut out six squares one foot by one foot using
expanding canned foam we glued those six pieces together into a 1 foot cube we then carved it into the shape of our shell using
A saw and some high grit sandpaper
Once we had the shape that we wanted carved out of it we painted on a protective layer of latex house paint and then you
Spackling to fill in any gaps or cracks in the foam and now it's ready, to be molded
This is the exact same process that i used to make mariokart shells for the devin supertramp video here's the foam shell from that build
as a reminder you don't have to use these techniques to make shells all sorts of shapes can be made this is just one fun
example there you have it now you know a quick method of making custom designs of your favorite video and movie pieces
Thanks for joining us for this project today and we look forward to teaching you how to mold and cast your creation in the next
video talk to you then
There's, so much static electricity on the foam that i try and brush it off and then all of the foam just like comes flying
back on it's like a magic trick appearing foam dust
blaghhh it's everywhere oh my gosh
that made it worse
hey guys i hope you're enjoying these new videos with nate as much as i am he's got some
phenomenal talent when it comes to building and crafting and he really loves what he does
Give, him some validation if you agree and i'll see in the next video